what memories do you have of you know
your screen mom and dad Jimmy Stewart
and Donna Reed what do you remember of
working with that
well I especially worked closer with
Jimmy and I just kind of added this bond
with him because my father was still in
Calif Canada and I hadn't seen him for
quite a while and he was so kind and
nice and so very tall and I'm short now
but I was shorter than when I was him
and he explained all the scenes and he
said you know I'm going to come in and
I'm gonna be very angry with you he told
me a little bit about it but keep on
playing so he was a wonderful person and
she was awfully sweet too but I had more
scenes and feeling with him mm-hmm how
about you Jimmy well I have a lot of
mixed feelings I had the opportunity to
work with Jimmy Stewart and Donna Reed
later in in all of our careers and I
remember they hired me to be the
boyfriend on the very first stoner Reid
show and so we were gonna read around
Thanks so we were gonna read around the
table and I saw Donna Reed at the end of
the table and so I went up and
introduced myself to her I said I'm
Jimmy Hawkins I played your son Tommy
Bailey and it's wonderful life she was
yes I know we used to call you Rip Van
Winkle
I said well Rip Van Winkle why was that
she said because you were so cute you
could sleep anyplace anytime no matter
what was going on and then they'd wake
you up and you'd be bright-eyed and
bushy table and I said and that's how I
got the name Rip Van Winkle